we have breaking news this morning from
London where uber is now under orders to
leave the city's public transport
Authority says it will not renew ubers
licence that expires next week the
company put out an angry response saying
far from being opened London is closed
to innovative companies Jonathan
Vigliotti is in London with this
decision Jonathan good morning what
happened good morning Gail ubers phone
app here in the capital could go dark in
the coming months the decision not to
renew the company's license affects
40,000 drivers and over 3 million
Londoners who click on uber is a cheaper
alternative to the city's costly black
cabs uber has faced criticism here from
unions and lawmakers over unsafe working
conditions among them including long
driving hours black cab drivers who have
struggled to compete with uber cheaper
fares they've also been critical staging
protests when uber first debuted in the
capital London Mayor Sadiq Khan he
supports this decision saying this
morning it would be wrong to continue to
license uber if there is any way that
this could pose a threat to Londoners
safety and security
uber isn't parked for good just yet
though they have 21 days to appeal this
decision viana yet another headache for
uber Jonathan Vigliotti in London thank
you